My friend has a theory that Elvis isn't really
dead. He says that Elvis got tired of the
limelight and faked his own death.
He also has a theory that aliens regularly
come to the Earth... but the government keeps
their visits a secret.
His weirdest theory is that all the leaders
of the world are actually shape-shifting extra-terrestrial
reptiles pretending to be human.
I have a hunch that my friend only says these
things to make himself sound clever down the
pub. You could say that I have a theory about
my friend's theories. But really, I'm just
guessing at what motivates him to say such
outlandish things.
My theory about my friend is just a theory
- it could be wrong. Maybe he really does
believe the things he says... in which case
there may be other explanations, or theories,
to explain why my friend is such a fan of
these conspiracy theories.
As for me, I'm a fan of scientific theories.
Like the Big Bang Theory, the Theory of Evolution
by Natural Selection, the Germ Theory of Disease,
Plate Tectonics Theory, The Theories of Special
and General Relativity and, my favourite, Quantum Theory.
Some people say that these are "just theories"
and believe that they have not been proven
by science. They talk and think about them
as somehow inferior ideas about how the world
works because they are called "theories" rather
than say "facts" or "laws".
But these people are mistaken. It's not entirely
their fault. It's because the word "theory"
doesn't mean quite the same thing in the world
of science as it does when used in general
conversation, where it can mean a guess or
a hunch or something that isn't quite known
for sure.
When scientists call something a theory, they
mean a set of ideas that does three things:
One: a scientific theory puts forward a comprehensive
explanation for things we observe in nature
Two: a scientific theory provides strong evidence
for that explanation
Three: Perhaps most importantly, a scientific
theory provides ways to make predictions about
the aspect of the world it explains, which
we can then test by further observation.
In every day conversation, we can dismiss
someone's idea about something by saying "it's
just a theory". But we can't dismiss the theories
of Darwin and Einstein and other great scientists
in the same way.
In science, an idea about how the world works
usually only gets accepted as a theory once
it's been tested and shown to be supported
by observations and other evidence - things
that are distinctly lacking from theories
about Elvis' continued existence, alien visits
to the Earth and shape-shifting reptiles running
the world.
What I'm trying to say is that it doesn't
make sense to belittle an idea in science
by saying it's "just a theory" because when
scientists refer to an idea as a theory, well,
they're giving it the highest praise it can have.